bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociologue
[Musique]
je me retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
vidéo puis détente on va parler en fait
simplement des livres des films des
séries de la musique que j'ai vu lu
écouté ces derniers mois alors j'ai noté
ce qui m'a marqué dans le positif comme
dans le négatif l'objectif c'est de soi
vous donner des idées de contenus
culturels à aller consulter ou pas aussi
d'avoir votre avis un petit peu voir si
on partage le même avis ou pas ça
m'intéresse donc voilà j'espère que ça
vous fait plaisir de me retrait pour ce
deuxième bilan culturel et puis bah
c'est parti alors j'ai mon petit carnet
dans lequel j'ai noté un petit peu les
choses que j'ai vu ces derniers temps
alors on va commencer par la catégorie
film alors eh bien la catégorie film
c'est pas des moindres parce qu'on va
commencer avec ma déception totale de
cette année je suis rentré en france je
crois que c'était en juillet et le film
que je voulais absolument voir c'était
annette annette de leos carax que je
voulais absolument voir parce que on en
avait entendu parler de d'un quoi moi je
m'attendais vraiment à un super film
d'ailleurs j'avais pas regardé bande
annonce je savais juste que c'était un
film musical qui avait apparemment une
esthétique vraiment top donc je me suis
pressée au cinéma pour aller voir
annette et quelle ne fut pas ma
déception mais vraiment mais poupe alors
je ne sais pas si d'autres par maison
partage mon point de vue mais vraiment
je n'ai pas compris l'engouement autour
de ce film c'est à dire que pour moi
annette c'est vraiment un avait enfin si
vous avez aimé j'aimerais bien discuter
avec vous parce que moi je ne vois pas
du tout et j'adore les films musicaux de
base c'est un genre que j'apprécie
vraiment beaucoup quand c'est bien fait
par exemple j'adore ça story les
demoiselles de rochefort je connais par
coeur voilà c'est entre que c'est un
genre qui me plaît donc a priori j'étais
plutôt bonne cliente pour ce film j'ai
trouvé que c'était niais et quand même
dit que ce n'était pas bien déjà dans le
style sais pas mais j'ai pas du tout
aimé et ensuite l'histoire enfin bon
j'espère un peu et en quoi que c'est pas
spoiler mais clairement on a un
personnage masculin donc qui joué par
adam de rêve qui connaît donc un certain
succès qui en suit delà est visé par des
accusations de violences sexistes et
sexuelles on sait pas exactement récit
est traité d'une manière de dire c'est
quand même un sujet qui a bouleversé le
milieu du cinéma avec mythe ou en 2017
je pense que c'était ça ouais en tout
cas c'est un traité comme un pardon
c'est un sujet qui mérite d'être traité
avec beaucoup plus de sérieux de rigueur
et on peut en parler mais on en parle
bien en fait elle a vraiment mais c'est
pour moi on passe totalement à côté de
la plaque on a sept personnalités du
ku'damm driver qui est très violent qui
est très manipulateur on n'a aucune
empathie pour lui à aucun moment et en
même temps on le faisait il ya aucune
émotion j'ai regardé ma montre plusieurs
fois au film c'est que vos lames envoie
la pantoufle je me suis dit soit c'est
tellement poussé dans les symboles et
c'est que je ne comprends pas parce que
je suis trop bête pour ce film toi
al'inverse on a voulu faire du
symbolisme à deux balles et ait bytes
parce que vraiment même le côté du coup
l'enfant cannes est la fille de la dame
driver et marion cotillard dans le film
est une une marionnette en papier mâché
et j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris pourquoi comment en
plus d'un an - elle devient une vraie
enfants enfin ça ne m'intéresse pas
pourtant harcha mdax a pas de violences
sexuelles ou sexistes ou autre on
n'aborde même le sujet du féminicide
c'est des sujets qui me parlait d'un
élément non c'est mal traités c'est pas
intéressant on s'ennuie l'esthétique du
film est belle c'est le truc que je
pourrais dire c'est que quand même
quasiment tout le film se déroule de
nuit les images sont très belles la
lumière est très belle mais c'est tout
voilà moi j'ai trouvé aucun intérêt je
n'ai pas aimé les chansons j'ai pas aimé
l'histoire j'ai pas voilà pour ceux qui
ont vu le film on est d'accord qu'il ya
un histoire avec marc hia qui est bref
c'est sur le bateau là voilà ça vous
rappelle à notre film je pars ce bref
voilà j'ai pas aimé du tout ensuite
deuxième film que j'ai vu c'est petite
maman de céline sciamma qui est passé
dans un dans un cinéma à istanbul que
dire j'avais adoré le dernier deux
derniers films dc cam a donc un portrait
de la jeune fille veut vraiment adoré la
intéressant on se sent en fait en tout
cas fait sa thérapie avec le film mais
ça sent trop en gros l'histoire c'est
que une femme vient donc de perdre sa
mère et elle est avec son mari et sa
fille est en fait un espèce de
d'événements surnaturels
on va dire fait que
sa fille y rencontre sa mère à l'époque
où elle avait le même âge qu'elle donc
elle se met à jouer avec une autre
enfant qui d'avoir dresse est un peu
près qui en fait sa mère donc c'est sûr
le rapport à la maternité à la
transmission etc c'est intéressant c'est
un peu émouvant par moment après
franchement moi c'est pas du tout le
film qui m'aura marqué ce qui est assez
particulier c'est que il n'ya quasiment
pas de musique dans le film c'est un
film extrêmement silencieux en terme de
deux sont rajoutés donc c'est une
ambiance assez particulière
voilà j'ai pas particulièrement aimé
après l'esthétique est une très belle
france est un film réussi mais voilà ça
m'a pas emballé plus que ça ensuite film
suivant j'ai vu de fadeur de florian
zeller j'ai adoré dans un film
incroyable extrêmement prenant
extrêmement émouvant ça parle du coût
d'un d'une famille fin aux traits d'un
d'une fille qui fait face à son père qui
est atteint on imagine de la maladie
d'alzheimer mais on le voit vraiment la
perspective du père c'est à dire que par
exemple l'actrice qui joue sa fille
change ce qui correspond à lui enlever
le fait qu'il n'arrive pas à reconnaître
exactement les gens autour de lui ce
film est en fait c'est une pièce de
théâtre qui se jouera à huis clos du
coup dans le film c'est pour ça aussi
que c'est aussi prenants d'avoir le huis
clos de l'appartement et on a parfois
l'appartement change externe enfin bref
on est je pense la première fois que je
vois un film comme ça où vraiment on est
dans le corps enfin dans la tête d'une
personne atteinte d'alzheimer et parfois
on est aussi de l'autre côté des
émotions de la famille c'est un sujet
qui fâche quand je suis pas la seule à
avoir un entourage qui a été touché par
cette maladie malheureusement et du coup
le film est bouleversant voilà c'est
vraiment ni plus ni moins totalement
bouleversant je vous avoue que en fait
je sais même pas ce que j'allais voir
quand je suis parti voir ce film ça va
tuer ma bonne humeur quoi clairement je
suis sorti de là mais en dés complète
relance à un film magnifique que je vous
recommande quand vous savez que c'est le
moment pour vous que vous êtes bien
entouré que potentiellement vous pouvez
vous changer les idées par la suite
parce que c'est un film qui est vraiment
dur mais qui en dit beaucoup sur cette
maladie et sur la vie et la mort voilà
des thèmes aussi universels ensuite au
niveau des séries j'ai visionné la
saison 3 de you sur netflix
bonjour et du doutais que j'allais pas
aimer parce que déjà la saison 2 avait
commencé à me décevoir notamment vers la
fin je n'ai pas du tout aimé voilà
vraiment je trouve qu'on a totalement
perdu le personnage d'origine vraiment
pour moi c'est raté complètement je me
suis ennuyé en regardant j'arrive à
faire deux choses en même temps quoi il
ya plus du tout cette
cette atmosphère un peu angoissante on
n'a pas non on perd en fait l'empathie
avec le personnage parce que la
particularité de hugh pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est qu'on suit donc un
personnage celui de jo qui tombe
amoureux donc d'une femme dans la
première saison mais au point de
développer un côté obsessif obsessif en
fait envers l cirque il ne la connaît
pas que l'apple contact avec elle mais
qu il se met à l'observer à la suivre à
essayer de comprendre sa vie et pour en
fait la protéger des personnes qui me
disent on a aussi donc en fait au début
on assure comportement digne d'un serial
killer clairement mais on comprend
pourquoi elle le fait on a une empathie
vraiment profonde avec lui et c'est
toute l'ambiguïté de la série c'est le
fait de de l'est mais malgré tout on
fait ça on le perd totalement dans la
saison 3 je trouve que les personnages
ne sont plus du tout accessible on peut
pas du tout se projeter dans leurs
émotions ils vivent dans la banlieue
huppée de los angeles ben moi ça ne
parle pas alors il ya tout ce que tu es
un peu critique de la société américaine
bon pour moi c'est du vu et revu c'est
même pas drôle enfin bref je sais pas si
ça fait rire les américains mais en tout
cas j'ai pas trouvé ça drôle
mais voilà en tout cas un gros nom pour
la saison 3 de you il ya une saison 4
qui a été acceptée qui en préparation
apparemment à voir s'il arrive à relever
le niveau mais franchement je trouve que
c'est l'intrigué vraiment soit
redondantes soit pas plausible c'est
vraiment pas agréable du tout à regarder
et c'est long j'ai regardé parce que
j'avais envie de savoir c'était
finalement une victoire pour eux mais
j'ai pas trouvé ça bien de tous ensuite
toujours niveau de série j'ai visionné
fit une série turque sur netflix ça se
regarde honnêtement après il ya plus de
critiques que deux points positifs à
tout ça l'histoire en résumé c'est un
grand psy très connu qui a un show à la
télé extra qui s'installe dans une
nouvelle maison et qui tombe éperdument
amoureux de sa voisine qui est danseuse
et qui va un peu comme ou en fait ça se
met à développer une obsession pour elle
et a essayé de manipuler sa vie à
distance pour qu'elle tombe amoureuse de
lui bon déjà tout le côté ou dans les
séries turques souvent istanbul et les
personnages sont montrés comme étant
dans une richesse absolue enfin c'est
très particulier pour moi c'est quelque
chose que j'ai du mal de manière
générale le jeu d'acteur est assez
particulier j'ai pas trop accroché j'ai
pas moi c'est pas une histoire qui
m'intéresse plus que ça il ya tout le
côté emprise et ses acquis et je sers
intéresser beaucoup de mes amis donc à
voir si ça peut vous plaire honnêtement
c'est pas une mauvaise série et je la
gardais en entier d'ailleurs j'avais
toutes les saisons même si l'argent ça
part un peu dans des délires bizarre
mais à ce côté voilà tout business en
fait les gens oui j'ai une journaliste
qui essaient de 2 décrypter les secrets
bien dissimulée dans ce milieu etc ah
bon pourquoi pas après pas non plus
génial et le truc qui est vraiment
embêtant je trouve ces cas des
placements de produits très souvent dans
quasiment tous les épisodes c'est pas
agréable quoi on n'a pas envie de voir
des pubs en regardant la série voilà par
contre autres séries que j'ai visionné
et que j'ai adoré c'est une série art et
qui s'appelle clan donc c'est une série
belge et l'histoire c'est donc que faire
comment elles sont ils sont cinq fois
cinq soeurs
enfin cinq soeurs du garçon de 4 ans oui
elles sont cinq en tout et les câlins
quatre de ses cinq soeurs ouais je vais
y arriver dans les embrouilles l'une de
ses soeurs et mariée à un homme qui est
totalement des estables vraiment le
cliché du mec très en retrait dans ses
privilèges qui appelle sa femme maman et
qu'il allait surtout les tâches
ménagères et donc les autres soeurs n'en
peuvent plus de cet individu et tente de
l'assassiner voilà vous êtes commence
par la mort de sept individus de leur
beau frère et on va voir votre maison
essayé de le tuer plein de fois et que
ça n'a pas toujours fonctionné comme
prévu voit la super série humour noir
humour féministes pour une fois aussi
c'est agréable voilà c'est un hymne au
que j'aime beaucoup que j'ai trouvé
génial la série est très bien produite à
retrouver sur arte en plus c'est gratuit
donc n'hésitez pas toujours sur arte
j'ai regardé un reportage qui s'appelle
bienvenue chez les sox qui est donc un
reportage sur le club de cricket de
saint-omer dans le pas-de-calais qui
accueille donc de nombreux joueurs
afghan puisque en afghanistan le cricket
est un sport très répandu contrairement
à la france alors j'ai visionné ce
reportage bien avant les événements
tragiques qui se sont passés en
afghanistan cet été je pense que c'est
aussi important pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas de regarder parce que ça
traite pas de l'actualité afghane sous
l'angle qu'on voit habituellement ni de
la crise migratoire sous l'angle qu'on
nous montre et remontre dans les médias
voilà c'est une histoire de
jeunes afghans qui sont arrivés en
france il ya quelques années qui suivent
une scolarité qui se débrouiller avec
tous les frais administratifs qu'il
rencontre qui à s'intégrer par le sport
c'est plein d'humanité c'est un très
beau reportage voilà en plus si vous ne
saviez pas originaire du pas de calais
donc voilà ça me fait plaisir de voir le
pas de calais sous ce jour là avec toute
la complexité que ses représentants y a
pas non plus de 2 comment dire on n'est
pas non plus en train de montrer que
tous les habitants du pas-de-calais sont
hyper accueillants justement mais voilà
cet entraîneur de l'équipe de cricket
qui est donc un local qui se bat pour
faire vu cette équipe pour envoyer ses
joueurs au championnat de france aux
championnats d'europe format c'est
vraiment une leçon un super beau
reportage que je vous conseille ensuite
on reste dans les films cette fois ci
c'est un film d'animation que j'ai eu la
chance de voir projeté à istanbul et
donc j'ai perdu mon corps jeremy clapin
c'est bien ça j'ai adoré en fait c'est
un long métrage d'animation à
destination des adultes c'est pas du
tout à destination des enfants je pense
on peut même être un petit peu
traumatisant pour des enfants de voir ça
en fait on est toujours dans la
perspective
villemain d'une main coupée et on
comprend que cette main du coup a perdu
son corps et cette main s'échappe d'un
frigo d'hôpital en âge imagine pour
partir essayez de rejoindre son corps
tout le long du périple cette main on
cette main comment dire touche des
choses on voit des paysages extra qui
lui rappelle des souvenirs de son corps
perdu et donc on bascule dans l'enfance
et dans le quotidien d'un jeune homme
qui est arrivé en france suite au décès
de ses parents et on suit en fait tout
donc sont enfin son intégration dans la
société française les difficultés qu'il
a eue pour en arriver à la toute fin du
film enfin on comprend comment il a
perdu sa main voilà c'est un très très
beau film très original qui est aussi
inspiré d'un livre qui s'appelle rapide
à happy end après un très beau film
franchement je recommande à 20% alors
ensuite on va passer à la catégorie des
lectures si vous ne savez pas je suis en
thèse dont le suspect un doctorat de
sociologie
donc
je lis énormément et encore jobson de ne
pas dire assez je pense que c'est un
phénomène que rencontrent tous les
doctorants votants vous dire que j'ai du
mal à consacrer du temps à mes lectures
personnelles ce qui me rend d'ailleurs
très triste a fait du coup dans mes
lectures marquantes de ces derniers mois
j'ai noté
une drôle de femme de leïla erbil ce
livre est vraiment mais mon coup de
coeur de ces derniers mois je les lui
cet été grâce à une amie qui me l'a
offert petit hic à cette phase par la
jeanne meyer du coup donc les la rbi
l'autrice turc or une drôle de femme
c'est d'ailleurs la traduction est
intéressante
du turc c'est une femme étrange en fait
en sorte qu'il ya beaucoup plus cette
nuance mais du coup destin comment dire
oh la la impossible de résumer se
livrent une drôle de femme c'est
vraiment l'histoire d'une jeune femme à
istanbul qui tentent d'entrer en fait
dans les cercles intellectuels de la
ville
on comprend en fait toutes les tensions
familiales que cela génère et un
déplacement de point de vue dans le
livre on passe aussi au point de vue du
père puis de la mer mais toujours centré
sur le parcours de cette jeune femme en
fait je pense que c'est assez rare en
littérature turque mais c'est un livre
ou même si vous ne connaissez pas du
tout la turquie c'est assez abordable
juste le chapitre sur le point de vue du
père a été un peu plus dur pour moi à
lire mais j'imagine que c'est qu'elle a
aussi réussi à décaler un l'autrice a
réussi à bien décalé le niveau de
narration est en tout cas très beau
texte même traduit enfin justement la
traduction est très réussi très belle
narration très belle histoire ça montre
toute la complexité de la turquie dans
ce cas d'istanbul de ces milieux
d'intellectuels de l'époque si vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion de venir à istanbul
où vous allez retrouver des mieux que
vous connaissez et qui sont aujourd'hui
sous un jour complètement différent de
ce qu'ils étaient à l'époque voilà je
vais pas vous en dire plus parce que moi
je permettre aux deux mots sur ce livre
mais je vous le conseille à 1000%
ensuite j'ai lu deux livres qui donc en
avoir les uns que les deux ensemble mais
j'ai un peu la même critique à faire
pour les deux le premier c'est la
bibliothèque secrète daraya qui est
écrit dans par la journaliste delphine
minoui et le second c'est que sur toi se
lamente le tigre de emilienne malfrats
tôt alors dans le premier la journaliste
donc raconte son enquête à distance donc
de piste en boule en l'occurrence auprès
de jeunes syriens qui ont organisé une
bibliothèque secret donc une
bibliothèque qui donc dans une cave dans
une banque à daraya en syrie en pleine
guerre est en fait qu'ils remplissent
des livres qui le trouvent dans les
habitations qui ont été bombardés c'est
intéressant forcément franchir c'est une
information intéressante de voir comment
ça fonctionne et c'est pour autant ma
critique et que j'ai du mal avec les
journalistes qui se positionne au temps
comme un acteur de l'intrigué je passais
où est ce que je veux dire mais en fait
delphine minoui se positionne vraiment
comme un
personnage de l'histoire donc nous
raconte comment elle a mené ses
entretiens comment elle a dû bénéficier
d'un par exemple d'un inventaire des
services d'une interprète en arabe
comment sa vie à istanbul et notamment
le fait qu'elle est elle se soient
trouvés très proche d'un des attentats
qui avaient élu rim semble en 2016 et
fait écho à la situation des personnes
en syrie accueillait le travail pour moi
ça me manque de ne pas que ça manque
mais pour moi c'est pas très
comment dire je trouve pas ça très juste
parce que
enfin ces deux sujets différents on peut
pas mettre en parapente c'est comme si
elle avait essayé de faire un film ou du
coup les événements se répondent dans
des dimensions différentes extra mais je
trouve que ça passe un petit peu à côté
de
la forme de retenue qui aurait été à
propos pour parler de ce genre de
situation on parle quand même d'une
guerre extrêmement violente j'ai pas
vraiment apprécié ce parallèle voilà
après c'est intéressant à lire c'est un
livre assez court voilà mais voilà je
trouve ça un petit peu délicat et du
coup en ce qui concerne que sur toi se
lamente le tigre ici on parle de mer
général on va dire de la situation des
femmes en irak même remarque là c'est
pas du coup elle n'est pas journaliste
elle se positionne pas comme tel mais un
petit peu alors je sais pas peut-être
que c'est c'est moi aussi qui
je suis chercheuse je me pose est énorme
en question du point de vue éthique
forcément je suis chercheur étrangères
dans un pays qui est qui déchaîne
l'orientalisme européen je me pose
beaucoup de questions éthiques et
forcément de voir des textes écrits par
des chercheuses au journaliste étrangère
/ dpi donc du moyen-orient ou du proche
orient forcément ça j'ai une part de
suspicion je pense qui est active dès le
départ du coup je vois c'est peut-être
que ça vient de moi mais que sur soi se
lamente le tigre pour moi enfonce des
portes ouvertes sur la situation des
femmes au moyen orient et au delà
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes
comment dire ça
participe à
la vision
dramatique de ce qui se passe pour les
femmes au moyen orient sans en montrer
les racines sans en montrer la diversité
sans montrer les résistances mise en
place par ces femmes d'un certain âge
femmes en tout cas donc évidemment c'est
très important d'alerter sur le drame
qui se joue en fait c'est pour des
milliers de femmes mais en même temps je
suis mal à l'aise avec la manière dont
ça a été fait voilà après intéressant si
vous connaissez pas du tout la notion
par exemple de crimes d'honneur et
cetera
mais si vous êtes déjà familiers de ces
familière de ces problèmes je pense que
c'est pas forcément un livre pour vous
ensuite j'ai lu une bd qui s'appelle sur
un air de fado qui est une bd de nicolas
barral nicholas sparks et pas désolé
j'ai adoré cette bd j'ai lu en
même pas une heure j'ai trouvé sa bd
magnifique mais point de vue esthétique
déjà très très beaux dessins très belles
couleurs donc ça se passe au portugal
donc dans le contexte de la d'abonnement
autoritaire des années 70 et c'est voilà
toutes ces réflexions sur la notion de
collaboration même passive avec le
gouvernement en place du départ à
l'étranger ou pas
voilà c'est je peux pas vous en dire
plus
résolues pour que si je vous invite à
aller regarder mais en tout cas très
très belle bd en fait j'aimerais
tellement pouvoir m'en tous les deux
bébés et les garder pour pouvoir
regarder les dessins et ceram et juste
ça coûte super cher quoi je sais que
c'est important de rémunérer les auteurs
et aux tris et les entrées dessinateur
par la même occasion et dessinatrice
alors juste travail mais c'est vrai que
c'est inaccessible financièrement quoi
enfin bref donc voilà en tout cas très
très belle bd très beau dessin j'ai
adoré et ils y arrivent dont je voulais
dont je voudrais vous parler que je n'ai
pas encore terminé mais je commence à en
parler c'est un roman qui s'appelle les
bergères de l'apocalypse avec s'inscrit
dans une trilogie et qui a été écrit par
françoise d'eaubonne donc france aux
eaux-bonnes c'est une intellectuelle
féministes notamment du 20e siècle et
elle a écrit un roman donc dystopique
qui s'approche du genre de la
science-fiction qui se situe en fait des
années après une grande guerre des sexes
qui répondent hui en fait à
l'éradication du sexe masculin donc des
hommes et donc on plonge en fait dans ce
monde où on a toutes les références qui
ont été totalement changé c'est à dire
que les villes ne partent plus les mêmes
noms par exemple paris s'appelle une
nouvelle lucrèce nouvelle vitesse pardon
il me semble ou alors le caire s'appelle
néfertiti fin voilà y'a plein de
changements il a des références à
nouveau de la spiritualité de cette
société 100% féminine qui sont
totalement différentes évidemment donc
par exemple envers un mélusine ou
valerie solanas voilà des choses très
intéressantes
j'ai pas encore finie parce que alors
déjà j'ai du mal à aboutir dans mes
lectures plaisir on va dire et de
manière générale j'ai jamais été une
grande lectrice de science fiction et du
coup j'ai vraiment du mal à m'imaginer
les choses par exemple comme on est dans
le futur dans ce livre et cave par
exemple des méthodes des placements qui
sont très futuriste de voitures volantes
ou alors elle peut facilement aller vers
d'autres galaxies d'autres univers et
séraphin du coup j'arrive pas à me
représenter par exemple comment elles
sont habillées ou comment justement sont
ces voitures qui vole enfin ça me pose
vraiment problème dans la projection et
du coup je mets beaucoup de temps à lire
voilà mais rien que pour libé et pour la
manière dont ces cris jusqu'à là je peux
vraiment vous le recommander et jade
avoir votre avis si vous l'avez lu alors
eh bien je crois que c'est tout pour les
lectures il me reste à vous parler
musique n'a pas commises il ya aussi
harry podcast
mais en ce qui concerne la musique alors
j'ai pas vraiment découvert beaucoup de
nouveaux artistes récemment j'ai
énormément les écouter les beatles et
jacques brel je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé en là en octobre-novembre je suis
rentré dans une phase je suis revenu
vers les basiques basique quoi au niveau
à
j'ai beaucoup regardé le compte
instagram de virginie cognait qui est
une artiste peintre que j'admire
énormément dont le travail me parle
beaucoup et l'autre artiste que j'ai
découvert récemment alors son nom
m'échappe face à andreas attendait un
bon en tout cas je vous mettrais son
sont at / sur l'écran juste ici après ce
qu'elle fait c'est qu'elles découpent
les pleins dans des cartes de paris par
exemple les cartes de ville pour faire
ressortir les rues et du coup elle a des
effets de lumière elle fait aussi
beaucoup de collages à partir de
vieilles photos et cetera je trouve ça
magnifique je trouve ça tellement
poétique de réutiliser ces photos pour
les transformer mais ça ça leur rend du
sens voilà alors que ces gens
potentiellement personne ne sait plus
personne ne sait plus qui ils sont oui
mais voilà ça chauffe ça extrêmement
poétique qui est beau délicat fin
raffiné moi je suis vraiment fan donc je
vous recommande d'aller jeter un coup
d'oeil à son compte en star et puis pour
finir cette vidéo on va parler podcast
puisque finalement je pense que c'est ce
que j'ai le plus consommé entre
guillemets du point de vue culturel ces
derniers temps alors
pour commencer je vous parle du podcast
en écriture qui est un podcast de louis
médias attendaient je m'installe
en fait louis médias moi je savais tout
mais du coup c'est une plateforme
payante de podcasts donc pas ce que j'ai
fait c'est que j'ai pris cette journée
c'est bon finalement je m'assure tout
est oublié donc j'ai payé un mois
d'abonnement mais je la trouve t
pourrait coûter beaucoup d'épisodes dans
l'écriture à l'origine celui que je
voulais absolument écouter c'était celui
avec ariane chemin le chemin à une
journaliste grand reporter au monde
c'est une femme que j'admire énormément
donc j'apprécie beaucoup le travail et
du coup j'étais assez curieuse de
connaître ces pratiques d'écriture l
épisode en plus froid s'appelle écrire
le réel donc forcément en tant que
doctorante en sociologie c'est quelque
chose qui me parlent beaucoup même si
évidemment on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
pratiques d'écriture et d' enquête mais
il ya des rapprochements à faire entre
journalistes et chercheurs et du coup
j'ai adoré écouter ce podcast déjà parce
que ça ça des faits en fait l'image de
la journaliste parfaite qui a un poste
de tri au niveau monde qui a écrit de
très beaux articles et serra et en fait
on comprend bien oui elle à la pression
de la deadline et oui elle sait pas
travailler trois jours avant elle se met
toujours à derna ministre et pourtant
elle a fait une grande carrière enfin
voilà j'aime bien ce côté ficelles du
métier on voit un peu les coulisses elle
revient sur des moments clés de sa
carrière notamment sur l' enquête
concernant la mort de zyed et bouna le
jeune garçon qui sont morts alors qu'ils
étaient poursuivis par la police qui est
pour moi la grande enquête dernier le
chemin à l'époque voilà elle revient
également sur la sphère benalla elle
revient sur le numéro qu'elle devait
consacrer à michel houellebecq et qui
lui a valu une vague de violences
une forme de harcèlement en fait de
dénonciation à télé et séraphin 2 voilà
des choses horribles qu'elle a vécu à
cette occasion chaud que ça dit beaucoup
de notre époque du milieu du journalisme
le seul petit bémol que je dirais par
rapport à cette interview c'est que ben
on lui demande aussi comment elle s'est
retrouvée à être en poste au monde et
bah franchement voir on la question que
je me posais le plus c'est comment cette
femme se retrouve là à quoi est elle le
dit un peu en mode ah mais moi j'ai
vraiment eu de la chance ce n'était pas
dedans mais ça n'aurait pas dû arriver
quoi en quelque sorte mais bon on n'est
pas non plus sorti d'un village et s'est
retrouvé au monde quoi c'est parce que
son père travailler à la bourse de paris
et du coup je travaillais pour sera le
directeur éditorial du monde enfin
quelque chose comme ça et du coup la
demande et de prendre sa fille et un
stage ce qui s'est passé à voir au delà
elle a fait ses preuves au point de
rester quasiment toute sa carrière au
monde à part quelques années au nouvel
obs il me semble bref à part ça génial
j'ai adoré donc je vous recommande
ensuite je n'ai pas changé mes habitudes
j'écoute quasiment tous les épisodes de
transfert qui est un podcast de slate
transfert du coup c'est des histoires
extraordinaires qui arrive à des
personnes ordinaires en gros
à des épisodes qui m'ont vraiment
en fait en train de prendre un tournant
un peu sombre quand même je réalise
âgées deux épisodes que j'écoutais
récemment qui me viennent en tête des
choses vraiment dramatique mais en fait
qui montre comment la vie peut basculer
du jour au lendemain dans des dimensions
totalement extraordinaire dans le sens
négatif du terme en tout cas c'est
toujours très très bien racontée par les
personnes directement par les axes est
arrivé mais un petit peu déprimant
rivaux podcast rubin produits voix je
vous recommande c'est agréable à écouter
j'ai également écouté pas mal de
podcasts et qui parlait d'inceste
puisque c'est quand même un sujet qui
est venu sur le devant la scène
médiatique depuis la publication du
livre du hac ami kouchner sur
l'inceste qui a été commis sur son frère
jumeau donc j'ai écouté dans le podcast
les couilles sur la table qui parle
d'inceste très intéressant est essentiel
tout simplement pour déconstruire tout
l' approche que la société a de ce
phénomène qui même un très grand tabou
très peu plus en charge et qui touche
pourtant énormément d'enfants en france
et de famille voilà à écouter d'utilité
publique et je finirai cette catégorie
podcast avec le podcast un terrain
voyage donc c'est un peu de casse du
palais d'été alors intéressant dans
l'idée je me suis dit sympa à partir du
t2 voyager découvrir une autre culture
voire je crois que c'était un peu ça le
le pitch du coup j'ai écouté le
l'épisode sur le mas salat scheid donc
le thé indien alors pour moi il ya
vraiment un gros billet exo this is an
orientalisant qui m'arrange gêné dans l'
écoute c'était vraiment dérangeant en
fait pour moi c'est à dire que on met de
la musique des bruits d'ambiance très
cliché en fait pas vraiment c'est ouais
c'est ça c'est un peu le cliché attendu
l'inde est à la fois je comprends pas ce
que c'est aussi tout la pratique du tai
quoi le le pot en terre cuite encore
molle qui du coup font dans les mains
vingt ok c'est intéressant mais il ya
toujours ce côté un peu les pauvres gens
qui n'ont rien et qui du coup vont enfin
je sais pas j'étais un peu dérangée par
sa est la chose qui m'a le plus dérangé
c'est que quand on parle de thé on s'est
quand même impossible de parler
d'histoire coloniale je sortirai
peut-être un jour une vidéo sur le thé
le café en sociologie moi ça vous
intéresse j'ai commencé à préparer mais
j'ai jamais tourné ce que j'ai du mal à
trouver l'angle qui me satisfait le plus
là le problème par exemple un moment je
sais plus comment s'appelle le monsieur
qui parle dans ce podcast mais il dit
que en inde les indiens en fait ne
consomme pas le tai chi et de luxe en
fait qui est envoyer systématiquement
vers la justice a en fait il dit mais un
peu pourquoi donc la vérité est que
depuis l'époque coloniale est le même à
penser à la route du thé des épices etc
steira les produits les plus nobles sont
exportés vers les pays européens et
maintenant les états unis de manière
systématique au point que les
populations qui produisent ces produits
de haute qualité ne bénéfice pas eux
mêmes de ces produits cette phrase
n'était pas très bien construite je suis
désolé donc tout ça pour dire qu' il n'y
a pas de mise en perspective historique
dire juste me parce que vous savez les
indiens ne consomme pas douter de haute
qualité donc c'est pour ça qu'ils le
mélange avec pain d'épicés du lait ok
mais franchement je trouve ça vraiment
choquant de ne pas dire pourquoi je sais
qu'on n'est pas là pour pour plomber
l'ambiance mais quand même ça on ne peut
pas parler de tes s'en remettre en
perspective un minimum la réalité qui
est la colonisation britannique en inde
france est quand même là peut-être que
je suis venu une rabat-joie franchement
dites moi si vous penser pareil ou pas
mais je trouve ça vraiment dérangeant
quoi sérieusement j'ai failli arrêter
d'écouter à ce moment là je me suis dit
mais stop enfin c'est pas ta manque de
précision c'est juste un peu de rigueur
intellectuelle et de de remettre les
pendules à l'heure que de dire ça
s'apprend de seconder et oui en effet
c'est vrai que parce que le thé n'est
pas de bonne qualité
les indiens ont développé cette
technique de le boire avec du lait des
épices mais d'abord des pourquoi parce
que la base le thé de qualité il aux
indiens ils pas aux britanniques ou
enfin bref bon sur cette note
d'agacement ba ex et je termine cette
vidéo ici j'espère que ça vous aura
varié découvrir du contenu culturel que
vous ne connaissez peut-être pas j'ai
surtout hâte d'avoir vos avis dans les
commentaires qu'on puisse en discuter un
peu plus parce que c'est le but de ces
vidéos quoi qu'on échange qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas d'accord d'ailleurs je
suis très contente de voir votre rue
pour ce format plus détendu merci à
toutes et tous de me suivre sur la
chaîne ça me fait vraiment chaud au
coeur n'hésitez pas à commenter cette
vidéo à mettre un gm à vous abonner à la
chaîne à partager bref à faire vivre
social buzz je vous retrouve également
sur mon compte instagram si vous voulez
suivre en plus mon quotidien de
doctorante en sociologie
après tout ça je vous dis à bientôt sur
ces logos
[Musique]